in some conflicts there is a clear good
guy and a clear bad guy say
america versus the dirty rotten godless
commie soviet union in the cold war
in other cases
maybe a little more of a complicated
conflict there is at least a clear ally
involved let's say the united kingdom
versus argentina in the falklands war
but in some conflicts say
the iran-iraq war for example
you don't really like either side and
you mostly wish that they could both
lose
it was this last sort of conflict that
just played out on the streets of
portland where a white leftist woman and
a vaguely ethnic leftist man
yelled at each other in the middle of
the street
i don't have time to waste some
colonizing she told me she told me to go
back to where i came from you see that
we don't drive
okay and as someone who's from here as
well i'm so tired of people driving like
you just did all right get on my face
get on my phone
wrong and then it's not really
admit that you're driving i knew you're
white i mean you have a colonizer it's
not about race
it is not about racism yeah it is
problem here
if you want things to change when you
[ __ ] oh so it's on me it's not me
call the race card don't you do not call
it shut up and don't even get in her
face do not get in her face you're
taking out you're not getting an
impression on me right now
give it a moment
if you want anything to change if you
want to shut up it's not on me to change
it's on you and your colonizer mindset
so get up out
i
i love it i love it i can't look away
like a car accident which there may have
been a car accident here eventually
there might have been i can't look away
i love how she screams it's not about
race
um
sure seems like it's about race for that
guy
and it's about race because the libs for
decades have cultivated and promoted a
decidedly racial ideology that says
white people are evil and every other
type of person is good and everything
that is in even the slightest way
european must be disparaged and
overthrown
because western civilization is evil and
now that ideology is coming back for the
libs for those white libs with a
vengeance
i myself
i happen to be immune to white guilt
perhaps this is because i am sicilian we
are the swarthiest of the arguably white
people uh something about the extra
melanin i think inoculates us to white
guilt perhaps but i do not hate myself
and i don't hate my ancestors and i
don't hate white people or any other
group of people because of their race
and i don't hate western civilization
i actually like my neighbors and my
ancestors and my country and my
civilization and i want to build all
those things up and i want for them to
succeed
it's a big difference between the right
and the left today the conservatives
welcome
everybody
they encourage everybody
any race any sex whatever
we encourage everybody to come on in if
they want to support our cause we are
constantly trying to win people over
we're always bragging about winning over
the old school liberals the old school
liberals are coming over to us the
hispanic vote is coming over a larger
percentage of the black vote we're going
to get it
the libs on the other hand
are not only not welcoming new people
they are actively excluding their own
supporters if they happen to be of the
wrong race or sex
they're telling white people including
white liberals to shut up telling men
including liberal men to shut up
they're telling women including liberal
women who oppose transgenderism to shut
up
they are eating their own they're going
after bette midler now for goodness
sakes they are devouring their own
and they have to devour their own
because their political program is to
devour
it's to break everything down
topple every statue
the revolution always eats its own
children right now head on over to
ring.com
knowles the summer is upon us it is time
for people to travel i think about half
my team is out right now they're all out
sick probably sitting on a beach sipping
a pina colada somewhere it's why you
need to have a ring you want to make
sure that your home is protected whether
you're in the home or whether you're
outside the home and you're on a beach
on the other side of the world ring
protects not just your front step you
know about rings video doorbell ring
protects not just your windows and your
doors from freeze fire flood the bad
guys but if you get ring alarm pro if
you become a pro just like me go pro you
can protect your physical and your
digital home cnet calls ring alarm pro a
giant leap for home security i love
these guys i totally i trust these guys
they've been with this show since the
very beginning head on over to ring.com
knowles right now that is
ring.com do not wait protect your home
make sure you can rest easy this summer
protect your physical and your digital
life ring.com
knowles the revolution is eating its own
the libs are pitting everyone against
each other the white libs
are now
going aft they're they're yelling get go
back to where you come from to the
native american libs
in whom they have cultivated this sense
of identity politics then the native
american libertarian calling the white
libs colonizers you've got the feminist
libs they're not so happy with the
transgender libs but the transgender
libs they say the feminist libs are
terfs they're phobic they're awful
they're everybody is at each other's
throats
it ki it reminds me of c.s lewis it
reminds me of the screw tape letters
where the screw tape letters is this uh
book
uh this
imagined a series of correspondence from
a demon to his nephew demon and they
talk about how
they're going to win over souls and and
ruin souls among human beings and the
thing you quickly learn about the demons
is they all just want to eat each other
they don't love each other like in the
good sense of love meaning willing the
good of the other person they just want
to consume and devour each other it's
kind of that way with the libs they're
just they're just devouring each other
right now you're seeing this with the
singer macy gray
macy gray is a huge lib macy gray is
such a big lib that she campaigned a few
years ago to get rid of the american
flag she said the american flag no
longer represents america it's a
terrible
image it's basically just the new
confederate flag and she was going after
the january 6th there is and she was
attacking half the country she is a big
time bona
card carrying lib and and macy gray just
went on pierce morgan's show and said
hey guys you know man i'm a big lib and
everything but um
transgenderism is it's kind of crazy
right
and i will say this and everybody's
gonna hate me but as a woman
just because you go change your parts
doesn't make you a woman right sorry
you feel that
i know that for a fact
she's right she's right stop clock twice
a day she's right she knows it for a
fact
just because you go in and mutilate your
body that that if you're a man that
that's not going to make you a woman
and she says this and she gets a whole
lot of backlash jk rowling is another
very liberal woman who has made this
point and now she is public enemy number
one for the intersectional libs they
call her a turf a trans exclusionary
radical feminist they're just they're
just hemorrhaging people from their
coalition on the left well if you don't
agree on transgenderism you're out if
you don't agree on white guilt you're
out if you don't agree on this that or
the other thing you're out you're out
you're right if you don't agree 100 on
abortion if you don't agree on
transiting the kids on drag shows and
public libraries they're just spiraling
all of these people who they could
ordinarily attract to their to their
side
they're they're casting them all out
bette midler oh my gosh bette midler
ever since trump was thrown off of
twitter bette midler has been my
favorite twitter account because she is
so oblivious and she so just
regurgitates the most base level
left-wing talking points bette midler
just got in trouble
she got in trouble because she said
women
women we're being oppressed right she
was just spouting ordinary
40 50 years ago feminist talking points
but she doesn't realize now that the
left is eating its own on feminism
because of transgenderism so she said
women are being erased they're calling
us birthing persons they're referring to
chest feeding they're all of the kind of
transgender language and then bette got
a huge amount of pushback
not from the right
from the left
so then bet said oh gosh okay she issues
an apology she says
people of the world my tweet about women
was a response to this fascinating and
well-written piece in the new york times
on july 3rd and it was this piece about
transgenderism raising women there was
no intention of anything exclusionary or
transphobic it was the same old s-h-i-t
women it's about the same
same old [ __ ] women all women have been
putting up with since the cavemen but
look i've fought for marginalized people
and i've always supported and adored
them and she goes and she's just
spiraling and she's saying no i'm a good
person
why are you coming after me i'm one of
the good ones no your talking points are
a little outdated bet that's the problem
she then tries to dig herself out of it
she posts a picture of the supreme court
but all the conservatives on the court
look like muslims they've got they've
got muslim headdress and a burka and the
beard's on and the implication here is
that they're theocratic or something
like that what bet doesn't realize is
the picture is very islamophobic
isn't it just like that first comment
was transphobic the second one is
islamophobic one minute she's going
after the transvestites the next minute
she goes after the muslims why because
five ten years ago this kind of rhetoric
would have been completely ordinary we
wouldn't even think about this sort of
thing the left would have been totally
on board with it but because the
revolution constantly has to accelerate
because it's constantly it never stops
it's always perpetuating itself
eventually
it's going to contradict itself
eventually it's going to eat its own the
people who constructed the terror of the
french revolution what happens to them
they get their heads chopped off the
revolution eats its own and poor bet who
isn't
she isn't the most up-to-date she's not
not firing on all those pistons okay
she's she's using slightly outdated
talking points and it's enough to ruin
her reputation among her comrades
hold up one second we are so close to 1
million subscribers and i know what's
going to happen the minute we get to 999
999 you know youtube's going to be
waiting on the button they're just going
to wait and then it's going to hit a
million they're going to nuke my entire
account but i don't care let's
accelerate this baby what will b will be
subscribe send the channel to your
friends never miss a notification we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you